hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it because there's no possible
way you folks will ever let me forget or
live this town so yes this is me finally
acknowledging for starters yes it's
possible for me to look a little bit
like dog walker the nostalgia critic I'm
not gonna rock this look for the whole
video so while I'm adjusting that I'll
explain why this video is even a thing
that is going to exist first off I
really wasn't gonna make a video about
Channel awesome and everything going on
with it
for a couple of reasons the first is I I
mean I have my feelings my opinions
about it but I have no personal stake in
it I don't know any of the people
involved I have never been part of
channel awesome I was never offered to
be part of channel awesome I have no dog
in this race beyond just my feelings of
the whole thing and there have been
plenty of people who also are involved
to have already done great videos
examining what it is that has gone on
the accusations and everything else so
here's your other big reminder why I
don't look like Doug Walker I I'm not
bald
so anyways moving along I like I said I
there are plenty of videos out there
from people who have either done really
good examinations of what's gone on or
are the accounts of the people who
actually are affected and are impacted
and our former you know producers for
channel awesome or that guy with glasses
which was the sight of us before I'm
gonna leave this off cuz I actually kind
of want to look his little like like the
nostalgia critic is possible so I didn't
want to I resisted adding my voice
because I figure it's just one more
uninformed voice in a sea of them and
that's not needed that the voices of the
people affected are out there they are
what should be getting listened to
unfortunately this is something that I
have not been able to stop kind of
thinking about and I don't I don't have
real-life friends to talk this out with
because while I'm friends with plenty of
other creative people most of them are
either writers or podcasters
and their interest in hearing about
what's going on with some of their
channel awesome is minimal if not
non-existent so I gotta talk this out
for my own sanity and so that means you
folks get this video so in case you have
not caught up or kept up with everything
that's been going on I'll try in bullet
point this really quick because I don't
want this to be a recap for my reaction
to what happened I want to try if I'm
gonna make a video I want to try and
make something that is a little bit
different from a lot of what else is
already out there so recapping real
quick channel awesome is the home of
most famously the nostalgia critic but
also a whole bunch of other producers
they it has a number a lot of people who
were aggregated through the site people
like some jerk with a camera I believe
her stuck me at some point Linkara
cinema snob there's a long long long
list of folks who either previously or
until very recently were producers for
channel awesome now I actually do not
know a ton about this because my main
knowledge of channel awesome is first of
all fairly young people were pointing
out that they thought I looked like Doug
Walker before I even started watching
nostalgia critic I started watching it
about a year ago and my main knowledge
of them is through YouTube and the
channel awesome YouTube page only puts
up the in-house products of channel
awesome itself it doesn't you know all
the producers who are on the site have
their own YouTube channel since some of
them I did follow some of them I still
do but I'm not following I'm not some no
longer subscribed to channel awesome I
haven't watched the latest video they
put out so there was a document put out
a couple of weeks ago and basically what
seems to have happened is a bunch of
creators and former creators former
producers for channel awesome basically
got together and put in compiled a list
of grievances and instances of what they
considered to be unprofessional improper
and/or downright skeevy behavior on the
part of people in the upper end of
channel awesome and like I said it's 73
pages that I think that that was a lot
of ways a big thing because they there
had been word over time as
various producers had cut ties with the
site folks like Lindsey Ellis and
obscurus lupa that there was some sort
of behind-the-scenes tension but I think
until all these folks got together and
compiled all their complaints in one
place the weight of it nobody had really
seemed to appreciate or add that up now
that end of it in and of itself didn't
have to be as big a problem as it is
what has made everything worse
and again I'm not going through the
original documented complaints I'll link
to it down below if you want to read it
what has made everything worse has been
channel awesomes responses that
President there have been to their first
one was a complete and total non apology
literally using the phrase we're sorry
you felt that way oh boy
which heads probably the worst wording
they could have possibly used you know
it's a great big sorry not sorry in the
wake of that response a whole bunch of
people left the site then they put out a
second response which was a more
targeted response responding to some of
the specific allegations in the 73 page
document only a handful honestly there's
a lot that they don't address at all
give them what they did choose to
address it's possible to read it either
as this is the only stuff they hate they
can make any case against and you take
it as the rest is true because they're
not addressing it or they're just trying
to cherry-pick stuff that they feel they
can be smearing the produce about and
the whole tone of the second statement
they put out is very much smearing it
uses the terms disgruntled and
vindictive to describe the people who
were relaying their experiences and
again I'm not going through a point for
a point but the the things that they did
choose to address they either addressed
poorly or failed completely back up
their assertion that the original claim
was wrong or the few instance where they
did back it up what they backed it up
with is kind of weak it's not great and
even then even if we take it for granted
that you know these few handful of
things they address aren't the case
they're still um there's still pages and
pages of pages of stuff
they didn't address so after the second
response as of my recording of this
there are only two producers who are not
direct channel awesome employees who are
still at the site one of whom even
though he has not officially cut ties
has removed channel awesome banners from
his Twitter and his site etc and the
other one appears to only be sticking
around for the sake of trolling so that
he can claim to be last-man-standing
after everybody else bails so is there a
way for this possibly to survive this
possibly to move forward because let us
not forget there have been a number of
YouTube channel scandals for lack of a
better term in the last year or so you
had a nice ignore over at screen junkies
you had Adam blonde peek at what culture
and both those channels are still around
there's a significant difference though
because even though Adam lumpy was at
that point kind of a face of what
culture he was not you know there were
plenty of other people behind him plenty
of other writers plenty of other
presenters who could step up and take
things over in his absence I just had to
pause for a snowplow it's April in
Vermont yay
and then in the case of what culture
Andy signor was very much one of the
driving forces of not what culture
screen junkies Andy signor was one of
the driving forces of what made that
thing what it was he created on his
trailers which is which was really the
the runaway hit for that channel I they
still had other people on staff they had
corporate there were people above him
and it was the same without him Blum
Pete unfortunately Channel awesome
that's not the case the people that the
accusations and allegations are being
leveled against are the people at the
top so it's not just a matter of being
able to cut them loose and the thing
keeps going I think at this point the
channel awesome brand can effectively be
considered dead it has little to no
value at this point and certainly
channel awesome as it existed as a site
that was an aggregate of not only their
own direct content but a bunch of other
associated producers that is you can
consider that dead there's no way that
can continue that does not necessarily
mean that we've seen the last of the
behind it specifically in regards to
Doug Walker the nostalgia critic and Rob
Walker his brother and his primary
producing partner it is possible that
they could still come out of this I'm
not gonna say unscathed they will be
scathed but it's possible that they
could recover from this because while
they do not go unnamed in the in the
document their names come up less
frequently and in not as many truly
egregious instances as the name Mike
Michoud who is a guy who I know very
little about because he's not one of the
public faces of channel awesome I was a
little bit it was odd for me to find out
that he was either than a person that
existed because it seemed like everyone
even behind the scenes people showed up
now and then now here's the thing the
channel awesome brand is as I said
completely tainted at this point the
Nostalgia Critic brand might have a shot
and honestly the nostalgia critic brand
is probably stronger than the channel
awesome brand was in the first place it
honestly it's association was probably
why channel awesome had much value
initially in the first place then you
know we gained it more from the other
producers but they're all gone now so
strictly speaking what would probably be
the smartest thing would be for Doug and
Rob Walker to cut ties with Mike mashhad
and as much as they are able to without
being able to be proven wrong because I
don't know what the case is but if they
can lay the blame for save the
statements that came out at the feet of
Mashhad said he wrote these we didn't
wear out they could possibly recover
because if you look at fan community
responses there is a certain reluctance
to put too much blame on my on Doug and
Rob from the fans who haven't JumpShip
or who feel really bad about having done
so now again that's not me saying
they're blameless in this I don't I
can't make that statement I don't know
enough but looking at what fans are
thinking there does seem to be a DC
contingent of fans who who want to be
able to be on the side of Rob and Doug I
don't think anybody cares about me on
the side of Mike Mashhad so that that
would be the best thing they could do
there's a problem with that though my
now the exact degree of this seems to be
something that's in dispute but Mike
Mashhad owns anywhere from a majority
stake in channel awesome to actually
being the sole owner of the brand and
the Nostalgia Critic IP how that even
happened in the first place I don't know
I can't speculate about but if nothing
else he he holds a very significant
chunk of the rights of the intellectual
property that is the nostalgia critic so
if Doug and robbed simply walked away
they could not take the nostalgia critic
with them they couldn't use the name
that couldn't use the look they couldn't
use the same format of videos all that
would be remaining with whoever controls
the IP and you want an example of how
that plays out fairly recently Stephen
Colbert now hosting the Tonight Show he
was sued or if not soon a
cease-and-desist I forget exactly what
it was but he will serve legal notice
from Viacom when he appeared on that
show in his persona of Stephen Colbert
from The Colbert Report because that but
even though it was his name it's his
legal name it's him that version of him
was very much a character it was a
caricature of a certain sort of thing
and when he appeared in that character
on his other show the folks who own the
intellectual rights to the character of
Stephen Colbert sued the real Stephen
Colbert over his use of that so this
will put Doug and Rob in a position
where they would have to come up with
something that is not the Nostalgia
Critic and then try and build that and I
can see why at the very least they'd be
very reluctant to do that because they
ended the Nostalgia Critic once before a
while back and tried to do other
projects none of which took off and
ultimately they revived the nostalgia
critic and I think they don't have
as many illusions at this point that
they can carry an audience without the
strength of that character and of that
brand what those reviews were now of
course everything I've set up to this
law at this point presumes that they
even want to cut ties with Mike Michoud
I don't know the nature of that
relationship but speaking strictly from
a business standpoint that that would be
the very wise thing to do the question
is what they're left with if they choose
to do that and again depending on what
other future things come out what other
details we get it may turn out that
Robin da
Doug and Rob are themselves separate
from Mashhad so tainted
anyways that they may not be able to be
you know do a rebuild regardless but
from the view that I have at this point
it is possible if they could get control
of the Nostalgia Critic
as an intellectual property away from
Mashhad if they could either buy him out
or you know what whatever they have to
do the problem is or at least the
potential problem because again I don't
know I don't know any of these people
personally but the picture of Mike
Michaud that's painted by the respond by
the original document and then also by
the responses because general consensus
again not proven but consensus from
number of people seems to be that it the
responses feel most likely to have been
written by him so he does not come
across as the kind of person who would
go guys I'm a brick on the neck of this
thing here you guys do what you can with
it I'll leave you to it
that's not that's not the the man that's
painted in the in the documents that are
available so that that would leave them
in a position where they may not be able
to get control of what is undeniably
they their brand it's what they make
their living on is the nostalgia critic
at the end of the day it's what channel
awesome was built on the back of it was
their most lucrative thing and probably
still remained so but at this point and
it also might account for the lack of a
direct response from
and Rob because so far the responses
have come just from a channel awesome
which is a company and not a person and
I have to wonder if they are simply if
they're either unwilling or somehow
hamstrung by possible retribution from
Mashhad over being able to put their own
statement out there I mean it is there's
something very awkward about the fact
that the responses have come in the form
of these two statements you know from
the company which is faceless and on the
on the channel awesome YouTube channel
there has been silence except for the
release of one episode of the nostalgia
critic which was probably already
finished but there's something very
tone-deaf about the choice to put that
out instead of a response of any kind
shape or form it just comes across as
very callous as very not caring again
there's been no apology for any of this
for any of what has gone on and and even
the stuff that they do dispute they
don't just be well and a lot of it they
don't dispute it is it's just another
very unfortunate situation and I don't
know what I hope for at this point
because as I said I don't know any of
these people personally I do certainly
hope that people who are currently
affiliated with the site who are not
named in the accusations people like
Tamra chambers Malcolm grey Walter
bidets II AK Jim might forget his last
name but the guy a guy who does the
props and such I I hope that
they they come away more or less
unscathed I know there's already been
some nasty stuff thrown at them by
people who are either just trolling or
have very misdirected anger which is
unfortunate because it is worth noting
that by and large the complaints in the
original document are either from some
are either or or both
from incidents several years ago or from
longtime contributors there's not much
there from newer people so it which
again could have given that if their
response had been something along the
lines of we're very sorry you know the
majority of the dates on this and notice
that there are fewer incidences from
more recent dates we feel we have
improved we will continue to improve
here's how we're gonna do that if they
put that out as a response I'm not gonna
say there would have been no fallout but
there wouldn't have been what there is
because really the mass exodus of
producers has been in the wake of not
the document but the responses and it so
often these things become worse than
they need to be because of the way that
entities respond to them I'll tell you
I'll try and keep this quick there was a
gay club that opened up in in Burlington
in Vermont on a year or so back I'm not
gonna get into full details but it chose
a name that some in the local LGBTQ
community felt was trans folk
transphobic and while I don't argue that
that it was not the intention of the
owner - that his response to that was
not oh oh I'm sorry well you know and
I'm not even saying he needed to
necessary changes name but his response
was there's nothing wrong with this
you're wrong for being offended you need
to come out and support me because
there's no other exclusively gay bar in
the area it was a big middle finger to
the people who took offense and
everything spiraled out of control
from there he kept doubling down
and lashing out at the community he was
trying to build as a customer base until
eventually the whole thing just folded
and these sorts of just bad responses
because I figured there's there's
basically when something like this
happens there's there's three kinds of
responses you can get from a company you
can get an apology and an
acknowledgement that something went
wrong which will usually be met with
some degree of criticism or cynicism but
probably the least amount of it you know
if you can lay out we acknowledge these
problems here's how we intend to fix
them that's gonna mitigate the damage
the best if you put out a response that
just feels like it was generated by a
machine that says we are very sorry we
hope to improve but don't lay out a plan
for how to do that or acknowledge any of
the specific things or specific people
who are hurt that is gonna that's not
gonna garnet you really much benefit of
the doubt at all but it won't make
things much worse unfortunately when
you're dealing with companies or
organizations that are run by one two
three people as opposed to you know
because the first two things that I laid
out that's what you get from a large
company like with a board of directors
or whatnot you get these really
mechanical responses that don't mean
much but usually don't make the
situation too much worse when you've got
companies owned by just a handful of
people people's anger and their emotions
bleed into these responses because there
isn't a check there isn't somebody over
them there isn't a committee of people
looking over this to make sure this
isn't a horrible horrible way to respond
to this and that's that's just what has
happened and so often in in almost
everything in business and politics and
whatever it's how you respond when
something has gone wrong that is what
will decide how big the problem is the
problem exists either way
you have the ability to mitigate it or
make it worse and they've just made it
worse and I don't have an overall point
that I'm Alania as I said this was
largely just for me I needed to get this
out I needed to talk this out because
I'm hoping it will occupy my mind less
now that I've said stuff that I've
talked about it and again I don't think
anybody should be coming to me as a
source on this I don't plan to do
another video on it I'm not you know
gonna do a breakdown of everything
that's gone on I would encourage people
to seek out the CAD the original
document the accounts and the videos
made by the people who were in that
document whether they put out videos did
tweets whatever there are some very good
look at and breakdowns that aren't just
hot takes that our detailed looks at the
document and the responses that they are
out there and I would encourage you to
seek those out if you want or if you
just want to stick your head in the sand
and ignore the term Channel awesome
every time you see it I would not blame
you I think having now you know talked
to all this out that I think that's kind
of where I am right now I don't want to
think about it anymore which is why I
had to make this video so that all about
wrap it up for this one guys the whole
channel awesome mess what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it please keep it respectful
I know this is a topic that has heated a
lot of people both either for or against
the channel and the people involved or
the people who've made the accusations
so as always I ask that you keep it
respectful but yeah let's let's see if
we can talk it out and and then move on
from at least for ourselves because I'm
not saying that anyone involved and it
needs to just move on they need to
process however they need to process
so if you didn't find this completely
just depressing and bumming you out you
can follow me on Twitter or support me
on patreon etcetera etc links for all
that stuff as well as the link to the
original document that I mentioned
that's all down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]